creepy things happening on horror movie
sets isn't a new thing just ask the crew
who made The Exorcist or Poltergeist but
you won't believe what happened during
the filming of Five Nights at
[Music]
Freddy's the first five nights at
Freddy's video game was released in 2014
and spawned a massive media franchise
thanks to the strength of its novel
approach to horror one of its core
elements is its cast of creepy
animatronic humanoids akin to a
dilapidated Chuck-E-Cheese band come to
life with murderous intent the Five
Nights at Freddy's movie that premiered
on October 27th adapts these characters
for the first time to the big screen
doing so it turns out caused a
particularly creepy moment on set in an
interview with Entertainment Weekly
director Emma Tommy recounted how she
sometimes witnessed firsthand the
animatronics moving on their own each
animatronic was operated by a
puppeteering team such that different
puppeteers controlled a single mechanism
each on one occasion she recalled seeing
an animatronics eye twitch the Puppeteer
in charge of that eye claim claimed that
she wasn't responsible for the twitch
suggesting the animatronic moved on its
own what the heck Tommy said we embraced
the quirks when they would do stuff that
we didn't necessarily command them to do
exactly we sometimes thought it was gold
and used it so it was super fun in that
way it felt like a real life element
based on these comments it seems that
shots of this happening are actually in
the Final Cut of the film which is
pretty cool just prior to the movie
premiering Bloody Disgusting interviewed
Robert Bennett who's credited as the
film's project supervisor and lead
designer Bennett works for Jim Henson's
Creature Shop the company responsible
for iconic puppets in numerous films and
TV shows including the Muppets and The
Dark Crystal Bennett happened to
corroborate emit tomi's account of the
puppets sometimes moving on their own
however he claimed to understand what
caused this to happen demystifying some
of the onset creepiness he explained I
know that there were several times where
there would be a signal between one of
the remote controls and a Servo would
glitch and Emma would be like oh my God
that's so amazing can we do that again
again well we'll try he went on to
explain that the Five Nights at Freddy's
animatronics were designed so that they
could appear intentionally glitchy when
necessary filmgoers then may not be able
to tell the difference between moments
where the puppets legitimately act on
their own and instances where the
puppeteers are in command of some of
their creepier movements thanks for the
heads up in an interview with inverse
Emma Tomi discussed how requirements
unique to filming mechanical puppets
impacted day-to-day operations on the
Five Nights at Freddy set operating
large animatronics it turns out isn't
easy she said getting the animatronics
up on their feet and then giving them
the brakes they need so they don't
overheat or so that the suit performer
has proper brakes all of that takes up
so much time by the end of the shoot we
were a well-oiled machine Tommy went on
to explain that there were distinct
versions of each animatronic character
designed to address the requirements of
different scenes throughout the film
some versions were entirely animatronic
whereas others functioned partially as
suits for stunt performers allowing them
to move the characters from inside
certain incarnations of Bonnie Chica and
Freddy specifically could even fit two
stunt performers at a time she said it
was a mashup of a bunch of different
techniques all of which Jim Henson's
Creature Shop brought to life in the
most Exquisite way given each puppet's
complexity it's unsurprising they didn't
always function according to plan
fortunately times when the animatronics
would move on their own didn't seem to
derail filming but rather added to their
distinctly unsettling
appearances